we wanted this truck traffic we want to
stop everyone so they asked so they
asked what's going on so they asked what
so it's important to them in their day
because it's important to me it's
important to Mike Brown's family is one
of our gardeners family you
and we're sitting down as you know
singing Kumbaya doesn't mean
while I'm like sitting down
I mean there's a huge presence
if you don't change things sitting down
I love the concept it's beautiful we're
all peaceful people it's like a big show
you got to sit back and watch and see
what turns out which you probably won't
be happy because you look we can't count
on the city
the officials to live there right they
haven't done nothing right so far what
if they done right look at Oscar Grant
somehow that dudes still got up we need
to remember that
dr. King invitados de Bryan is the voice
on the unheard
and sometimes in order to be heard
unempowered people
have to do a straight as somebody who's
more just made in protest my life I
don't even
non-violent civil disobedience as a way
to
k for social change
they do that in the 60s how much was
this that much was accomplished I'm just
asking questions I like okay like
nothing was accomplished because we're
still here today we still have black
young and good black men getting killed
in the streets we still have broke
police brutality against up air every
race I don't want people hurting each
other that's kind of a very hard than
you know I understand people are very
upset and I understand certain people
want to show their anger through
destruction like I say you know
have the right to be found they're angry
I'm angry I wish I could be stuff
so I feel like shit will yeah we're
gonna be out of your killing we might as
well be out here all doing it together
it ain't fear of y'all get to do it we
might as well get to do it too what it's
dad this is making them more attention
to us and
it's not ready fire because
you
listeners this is a live they brigands
them do I advocate violence now is this
sometimes useful yes
you